hey everyone it's sarah with
registernursern.com and in this video
we're going to be solving some capsules
and tablets
dosage calculations and as always
whenever you get done watching this
youtube video you can access the free
quiz that will give you more practice
problems
so let's get started our first problem
says the physician writes an order to
administer an oral medication
the order says administer 0.1 gram by
mouth
once daily pharmacy dispenses you with
100 milligrams per tablet
how many tablets do you administer per
dose
so from the scenario we have pulled out
the most important information we need
to know in order to solve our problem
so first we need to know what was
ordered the doctor ordered .1 gram
once daily pharmacy has supplied us with
tablets that say
there is 100 milligrams per tablet so
every tablet we have there's 100
milligrams in it
and our problem wants us to figure out
how many
tablets we're going to give with each
dose so this patient is only receiving
it
once per day and we need to figure out
how we can
give this many tablets in order to equal
this dose
so to solve these problems i'm going to
use dimensional analysis
and i have a whole series that you can
access where i show you how to work
dimensional analysis
and we work a bunch of different dosage
calculation problems
so let's set up our problem first we're
going to start with what was ordered
so 0.1 gram
was ordered and it's ordered once daily
so
that's our dose one dose
and we have to get tablets per dose
that's what we're trying to figure out
so we're supplied with tablets that are
in milligrams so right there we're going
to have to
start converting so remember you have to
know your metric table
commit this table to memory so we're
going to go ahead and we're going to get
to milligrams
so from the metric table we know that
one
gram equals a
thousand milligrams
grams cancels out so we're now in
milligrams
and now we can plug in what we have on
hand
so we have on hand tablets so
each tablet has a hundred milligrams in
it
equals one tablet
okay and we're where we need to get we
need to get to tablets
per dose so we're ready to solve so
we're going to multiply everything at
the top everything at the bottom and
divide
so when we multiply everything at the
top and bottom we get
100 over 100
and then we're going to divide that out
100 divided by 100
is 1. so our answer is one
tablet per dose is what this patient is
going to
receive our next problem says the
physician writes an order to administer
an oral medication
the order says administer 25 milligrams
by mouth
bid pharmacy dispenses you with 50
milligram
tablets how many tablets do you
administer per
day not per dose so we pull from our
scenario the most important information
we need in order to solve
so we need to know what was ordered so
25 milligrams
twice a day that's what bid means by
mouth and we're supplied with
50 milligram tablets so each tablet is
worth
50 milligrams now our problem wants us
to solve for how many tablets are we
going to give for the whole
day not per dose so make sure you really
pay attention to that part
of your problem because if you just
solve for tablets for those you would
get it wrong
okay so we're going to use dimensional
analysis to solve and this is going to
be like a two-step problem
okay so we're gonna start out with
what's ordered so the physician ordered
25
milligrams that is equal to one
dose and we are supplied with
tablets that are 50 milligram tablets so
we don't have to convert like we did
with our last problem so we don't have
to really use the metric table
so 50 milligrams
is equal to one tablet
okay tablets per dose so we'll go ahead
and solve and then we'll plug in for our
next step
so when you multiply everything at the
top and everything at the bottom you get
25 we're gonna with 50 and then we
divide that
out and we get 0.5
tablet per dose
so one dose is going to equal half a
tablet
but we need to know how many tablets
we're going to give for the whole day
so we're going to use dimensional
analysis to
demonstrate that so
we know that the patient needs two doses
that's what bid means so
two doses is how much they're going to
get in one
day and we know one dose
equals half a tablet
okay dose doses cancels out and we're
left with tablets per day and that is
where we're trying to get that was our
destination
so we're going to multiply everything at
the top everything at the bottom and
then divide and get our answer so when
you do that
1 1 divide that out of course you get
1. so it's tablet
per day is what this patient will be
receiving our next problem says the
physician writes an order to administer
an oral medication
the order says administer two milligrams
per kilogram per dose
by mouth every six hours as needed for
pain
pharmacy dispenses you with the
following 20 milligrams per capsule
the child weighs 22 pounds how many
capsules do you administer
per day not per dose so again we have
pulled the most important information we
need in order to solve this problem so
we need to know what's ordered the
physician has ordered two milligrams per
kilogram per dose
every six hours as needed for pain so
for every kilogram this child
weighs we're going to give them two
milligrams per dose
so our drug is weight base and we're
supplied with capsules that are 20
milligram capsules
and we're given the patient's weight
which is 22 pounds
and we need to know what to solve for so
we're solving for how many capsules
we're going to give them
per day so in that whole day not per
dose
so what we're going to do is we're going
to set up our dimensional analysis and
this will be like a two-step problem
like how we did before where we solve
for the individual dose and then we'll
figure out how many we're going to give
them
the whole day so first what we're going
to start with
is plugging in the patient's weight
because
this is in pounds we have to get to
kilograms because that's how it's
ordered
so let's go ahead and plug that in so
our patient weighs
22 pounds
and we know from the metric table that
there's 2.2 pounds in one
kilogram so pounds cancels out
now we're ready to plug in what was
ordered so
for every kilogram this patient weighs
we're going to give them two milligrams
per dose kilograms cancels out
now we're going to plug in what we're
given what we're supplied with
so we're given 20 milligram capsules so
there's 20 milligrams
in one capsule okay so milligrams
cancels out we're left with
capsules per dose but remember we got to
get to capsules per day
so we'll go ahead and solve this
multiply everything at the top
everything at the bottom when you do
that
you get 44 for the top 44 for the bottom
you divide that out
and you get one capsule
per dose now we need to figure out how
many they can have for the whole day
because this patient can have this every
six
hours so let's plug this in and figure
it out
so we know that 24 hours
equals one day
and we know that this patient can have
this
every six hours every six hours what can
they have
they can have one capsule
so that cancels out our hours and we're
left with capsules
per day which is what we're trying to
solve for so we're going to multiply
everything at the top everything at the
bottom and divide
when you multiply everything at the top
you get 24 everything at the bottom you
get
six divide that out you get four so they
can have
four capsules per
day and that is our answer okay so that
wraps up this review
over capsules and tablets and if you'd
like some more practice problems don't
forget to access that free quiz
and to check out the other videos in
this series